bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you
subscribe to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account
or you can deposit crypto and take out a
us dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get into
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got a very
very special treat for you today i have
general thomas here he's a
retired four-star general and the former
commander of the u.s special operations
command thank you so much for doing this
sir
thanks bob good to be here absolutely
let's just kind of
start off with you've got this
incredible storied
military career one of the nation's
greatest leaders walk us through kind of
your journey
uh in the military and then uh kind of
transitioning out what you're doing
today
uh well at the risk of coming off with
uh you know what seems like false
humility
uh while why a lot of people claim least
likely to be here
i am pretty sure i could compete uh you
know very well in that space
um i'm the oldest of six kids grew up in
the philadelphia area
um and all the kids were progressively
smarter than me
and again it sounds sounds like false
humility but it's doctors lawyers it
specialists
rns and biochemical engineers you're
literally in that
in that kind of descendancy um and so
i literally mucked through uh 10 years
of
schooling my parents thought i was the
biggest underachiever on the planet
and uh and i was very close to being
detained for you know
juvenile delinquency uh and i got uh
you know uh blessed by a bolt from the
blue
uh visiting west point with my little
brother a cub scout
i'd already quit the cub scouts because
they were too regimented for me
um and as i hit west point uh between my
sophomore and junior year um it just
impressed me that i needed
i went back home and literally told my
mother i need this place
and she poo pooed it she was my biggest
supporter but she thought no there's no
way you're gonna
you know correct yourself and i say the
first thing i need to do is
uh i'm in catholic school the nuns will
never believe it i need a bump from
catholic school into private school i
get a haircut and start doing the right
things
and that literally and i i look back
because i had
just such an utter lack of maturity back
in those days for
anything you know down the road or what
i might do with myself
but i look back now to that one you know
incredible
um seminal moment for me that then
you know birthed a a four decade career
in the military that uh that was
just uh you know pretty historic i have
friends that joke that
uh and it's probably not too far off
that i'm the forest gump for the last 40
years of
our military experience because i
literally have been in almost every one
you pick a
situation or and or a you know a uh
you know historic moment in our military
and i've happened to have been there
by hooker crook um in that time frame in
the four decades i
i uh have been married to the same
great uh woman for 36 years
uh while we've been locked in for covid
for the last year we've discovered that
the secret of our
longevity uh is that i was gone most of
that time
so uh she's even uh more revered for
having put up with me for all those
years
we have two great kids uh she gets the
credit for raising and they're both west
point graduates
both have served our country um as
soldiers i'm very very proud of them
uh and then uh most importantly we have
four grandkids now so uh
you know um it's uh that's where we are
now at this point in time and i'm
uh learning what i need you know what
i'm gonna be when i grow up after the
military because i'm now in that phase
of life
you you've had a uh a full life for sure
and much more to come
uh i want to talk a little bit just
let's start with kind of the military
experience
you were able to really uh experience a
number of different
uh situations both foreign and domestic
uh and when i asked for questions on
twitter one of the
main topics is just kind of the wars in
the middle east right so iraq
afghanistan
maybe kind of just give us a quick lay
of the land in terms of your evaluation
of just
where are we with those um and kind of
what are the things that people should
be paying attention to
or talking about today as we look at
kind of the wars that we're currently
engaged in
yeah this is an incredibly tough uh
topic um i don't think it's discussed
thoroughly enough and that's part of the
problem
um i feel expert uh in terms of
experience
uh and that i served every year from
2001 to 2019 when i retired
i was there for all of or parts of every
year
um in afghanistan and then i have about
four to five years across that time
frame of experience in
in iraq uh so i'm both an expert and i'm
to blame right uh yeah i'll accept that
that
i was uh not part of the solution um
first of all i think it's too cliche and
it's very easy for politicians to
uh disparage endless wars when reality
is it's kind of like the old
theory if you don't know where you're
going any path will get you there but in
some of these cases we didn't have a
strategy
for war termination for what it was
going to be like at the end
or at least what we wanted to be like
and we fumbled
afghanistan was sort of righteous we got
attacked from there we went with
our blood up it was a punitive raid uh
and then we progressed into
nation building and things like that
that we never wanted to get into in iraq
you could argue that
we all did a student body left at a
particular point in time
for reasons that you know politicians
laid out to us i was a relatively junior
officer at the time
and then we created our own worst
nightmare we created an insurgency
as the occupiers in iraq after we
dismantled all the security apparatus
and we got stuck there and so these
things have just festered
mostly because and and i i don't mean
this in any way political
we've had an end date instead of an end
state type approach
and so across multiple administrations
we have anchored
a hard date that we're done by this date
well what's that do for your adversary
it just tells them hang in there the
united states will lose patience and
then they'll leave
um and in every case we've been bolting
them so uh we have we have
mucked along like this for for 20 years
now uh specifically for afghanistan
and it it it annoys me it i take it
personally
when there's commentaries the general
officers thrive
in the military-industrial complex
thrive on this i can't speak to the
military-industrial complex i'm not part
of it in the afterlife either
um but every general officer or admiral
that i know
um has a son or a daughter serving in
the military
we're very cocooned in it in kind of our
our relationship and the good news is
our kids like the profession from their
attachment or their connection to it
a lot of them join but none of us are
advocating for
endless wars or these situations where
we're putting our kids in harm's way
literally with skin in the game
but that's very again it's it's easy for
that to be played off in
in in political discussions as oh those
generals
who want war um you know i was a colonel
when i went to war in afghanistan for
the first time
uh and then you're a rose to you know to
to my
ultimate rank yeah it's one of these
things where
i always tell folks and uh most people
on the podcast but for those that don't
uh i served in iraq for uh for a year
and
uh you just talk to a veteran especially
someone who's been to a combat zone and
they are usually
uh the closest to a pacifist that you
will find right in the sense of
uh they don't want to go they don't
think that uh we should be sending
soldiers but
if you send them they will do their job
and they will do their job well
um and so i think that it's kind of a
very nuanced conversation
talk a little bit this idea of kind of
an end date versus an
end state um there's a lot of folks who
just say well you know
end of 2021 let's just pick up and leave
kind of what would the
uh the negative side effects of doing
something like that be and then i guess
you know fully understanding that it's a
complex issue but just kind of
how do you think we get out of those two
wars if at all possible
yeah i i probably should have started
with and and
i'll stay now that everything i'm saying
is my opinion
um interesting phenomenon in the united
states these days you have a lot of
former generals and admirals who are
very prominent um it
it's bred two rabid thoughts
you know go figure on either side of the
spectrum that we should keep our pie
holes shut forever and never be heard
from again
or we are somehow uber citizens who know
more about
you know this great american experiment
than anything else i i don't
i consider both those you know dis
discards uh at the end of the day i'm a
citizen i was a citizen before i joined
the military i'm still a citizen
um i don't represent some cabal of
retired general officers or
the socom secret society or anything
these are my opinions
you could take them uh or leave them um
you know um for the for the discussion
about could we pull the plug
and here's the other i i tell this to
actually folks in the private sector now
here's the problem with being a military
professional thrown into one of these
conflicts
uh we desperately want to win for the
nation so we're way too close to the
problem
we probably are the most myopic bunch
out there that hey we're making progress
we want to see progress everywhere
i mean the most uh refreshing thing for
me to see in kabul
when i was back there the year 2012 to
2013 for the entire year
in charge of special operations was the
multitude of young
afghan girls all in their uniforms going
to school which we enabled
it it would not have happened if we
hadn't done that and it will absolutely
be
you know turn back i believe if if we
just pull the plug but the bigger as you
pull up from this thing
is the acknowledgement that this is an
ideological struggle
this was a group of people that attacked
the united states of america for
for their reasons um the ideology is
still very strong
even though we have crushed al qaeda
even though we have crushed isis
physically from a military standpoint
we've done little or nothing to to
really get at the ideology
and so if you pull the plug i think that
afghanistan will trend badly
to become a sanctuary again for bad
people who will actually be celebrating
that they defeated us much like they
defeated the russians or the soviet
union back in the day
and you should expect more of it to come
at us so what what should be the end
state
is some sort of sustainable security
where you and i never have to worry
about you know working in high-rise
buildings in new york city
or the pentagon again and ironically one
of the companies i work for
is on the 80th floor of one world center
i mean they have a difficulty still
renting above the 80th floor
because people think that there might be
you know another another episode
that that might occur so we're in that
dilemma of
how do you we should pull out we i mean
we should absolutely uh reduce our our
signature as much as possible
enable and empower the host nation to
take care of their own security
but absolutely leave some sort of
insurance policy in so that we never get
surprised again like we did at 9 11.
yeah and you know obviously throughout
this entire conversation there's so much
nuance there's so much complexity
uh we're going to spend about an hour
and a half talking so uh for those that
are listening just bear with us as we
kind of move from topic to topic and uh
and please don't assign any malice uh if
we skip over something
uh it's more so just us trying to get
everything in
general talk a little bit about just
kind of technology on the battlefield
obviously uh having the seat that you
sat in from the special operations side
usually those uh warriors are
you know having the access to the top
technology they see kind of things
before
uh the the general military would see it
how has that evolved through your career
especially while we've been at war for
the last 20 years and kind of just maybe
what's like the state of technology on
the battlefield today
um great question and i i was lucky to
serve with
uh folks who and i i saw one of your
previous
podcasts where someone acknowledged
people being the difference people are
the decisive advantage
um i don't know why that's an epiphany
for some some folks or that we have to
rediscover that
and so i was blessed by uh working with
teammates
who were always trying to come up with
new better ways to you know gain that
that tactical uh technological advantage
constantly the hardest thing to do and
actually
the higher erosion rank was to harness
the you know the good thought fairy
and say okay money's into that program
but with with some sort of agility to to
springboard elsewhere when something new
or better came up
and then to be able to scale it to the
entirety of our force uh so that we were
interoperable
um so to your point um the the folks
that i
work with in the special operations
community are riding
leading edge technology real time um
you know almost you know not quite the
degree that you know uh you know some of
the
folks i'm associated with now but right
and trail with that where they know
what's out there in the end they are
already applying it you know uh
tactically or operationally
uh in in the living laboratory that
we've been afforded for the last
bunch of years um so it is you know it's
very refreshing to see how they
understand the technology can and can
implement it it is incredibly
frustrating even more so for me now that
i'm out of the military
on how inept the department is in
leveraging the technology that's
available
um for all the things i just described
if it's thrown in into the milieu of
the department of defense and its
programming approach an acquisition
approach
that's a five-year seven-year at least
acquisition cycle
and you know how fast tech is changing
inside that cycle that
that's that's a recipe for being you
know an anachronism right right from the
beginning so
we have to smash that um you know that
gap
and partly is the idiosyncrasies of the
department uh to be able to to really
leverage
uh the extraordinary technologies that
are available today and in the future
i want to throw out the names of a
couple of types of technology and just
have you refund you know your thoughts
and how that's evolved
uh maybe probably the most famous one
when people think of technology in the
military is kind of all the drones and
unmanned aerial vehicles kind of how has
that evolved over time and how do you
evaluate where we are today with that
yeah you talk about technology that was
turned on us a little bit
um and if you'll remind me later on
because i
i was as uh myopic and and dawdling as
anybody else in
in service until i had a you know the
epiphany moment with
courtesy of eric schmidt and it's been
written about but i'd like to come back
on that but the drone piece
it was kind of fascinating in that uh
early on uh in places where we didn't
have
access we leveraged our drone technology
to great you know to great uh success
uh think of mq1 predators think of mq-9
reapers
think of all the exotic space-based
stuff we had to see into places and to
discern
targets if you will i know that's
unsavory to some people but that's the
nature of warfare
and then apply in the most precise way
possible and i can't emphasize this
enough that
it was a it was a non-start it was a
mission failure for us if we had any
collateral damage we wouldn't take that
shot
if we thought we had any collateral
damage in terms of innocent civilians
you know in the mix but we leveraged
that stuff to to a great extent
where i say it was turned back on us um
i was out in vicinity of mosul iraq
in 2015 or 16 and mosul was my hometown
for 15 months from
uh september 07 to december 08. um
and in this timeframe in 1516 isis was
now taking
uh dji uh quadcopters and equipping them
with little 40 millimeter grenades on
on the bottom of them and they would
literally just send up these off the on
the
off-the-shelf quadcopters find your
locations and then drop
these uh these 40 millimeter uh grenades
with a little shuttle [ __ ] device to
stabilize it
the day i was out there or shortly
before i was out there was called the
day of the drones by the iraqis
and the an isis on that day in a city
about the size of philadelphia
had put up about 70 different
quadcopters many of them armed
and at one point in time they had a
dozen to two dozen up and we had no
response for them and think of this we
had air superiority every pointy nose
fighter in the world
was above us to provide us that sort of
air cap but underneath that you had
off-the-shelf technology that was
wreaking havoc for us
um and and caused us to you know do a
complete turnaround
that is only the precursor uh for
swarming
unmanned technology in the future and
this this this is not just a war zone
challenge this is a new york city
challenge this is a philadelphia
challenge this is any city that's out
there
that some yahoo wants to leverage that
technology uh
again to to do bad things it's something
that we need to roll up our sleeves and
understand
as a threat and more importantly to come
up with appropriate counters that uh
that will keep us safe yeah what you're
really highlighting is there's almost
this element of as we improve
uh we're also teaching the insurgency
kind of some of the techniques and
techniques
that they can pursue as well another
type of technology that has become more
prevalent over the years is
everything from artificial intelligence
and machine learning
so kind of just the ability to use
software to become smarter to
analyze data more predictability to it
what's your evaluation of where we are
there
yeah and you you've actually you're a
great street man excuse me
um you've got me back on the one
epiphany moment i had
um about a month after i took over socom
i was very busy as the jsoc commander
before that the joint special operations
command for those
run acquainted uh phenomenal uh command
that
that i really did not want to leave it
was the best job i ever had but i got
pushed up to uh
it was probably the peter principal
played to the four-star level to be the
socom commander
but in my first month in the job i
hosted a visit
uh headed up by my former mentor and
friend bill mcraven
former socom commander who was in charge
at the
at the direction of the secretary
defense of the innovation group
at uh in the department of defense and
it had the eric schmitz of the world and
a bunch of other
you know very very bright and talented
folks to look at the department
and to honestly try and help us leverage
technology
and so a month into command i get this
uh coterie of people descending on socom
they spent a day with us and at the end
of the day we're riding down bay shore
boulevard not too hard farm
from my home here in a typically black
suburban right
and uh eric schmidt felt compelled to
give me a report card
on special operations and in short order
and you know not lacking any confidence
he said your people you amazing people i
thought check if you took nothing else
away
incredible talent you said you
prototyped pretty effectively and we had
taken them to our softworks facility
where we try to do
you know rapid you know prototyping etc
and i thought yep we've been failing
fast long before i ever read about
uh you know that that thought you know
failing fast
um but he said you absolutely suck and
he was actually more colorful than that
in terms of applied uh predictive
computing machine learning etc
where is he going with this he then went
on to say general i know you live
in a very complex problem but if i got
on your tent for
a couple days a week i think i could
solve most of your wicked problems to
simple up down switches
with advanced algorithms he might have
sent quantum computing
but about that time i was ready to kick
him out of the car because i thought oh
you're so arrogant how could you not
understand the complexity
of what we do and luckily admiral
mcraven engaged him because it allowed
me to think for a moment
and it smacked me in the head that oh
he's absolutely right
what google what these companies are
doing in terms of applied machine
learning
is absolutely apropos to almost
everything i can't think of any
exceptions to be truthful
of what we do in the military as if we
embrace
and and leverage this technology um and
so we went down the road i hired a chief
data officer for socom
phenomenal talent who's now the defense
department's chief
data officer uh and then we proceeded to
try and educate our force because as you
know
the biggest challenge is a lot of people
can spell ai and they know nothing about
neural networks they know nothing about
bayesian analysis
i'm and i'm the dumbest guy in the room
but you need to wrestle with this
every day to understand it especially as
it's mated with what problems are you
trying to solve what's the data that's
pertinent to it how do you
how do you arrange that because most
importantly and this is where i think
for all those that are
opposed to leveraging and enabling ai
we've had the luxury for the last 20
years of not having to make
for the most part time sensitive uh
compressed decisions under under
incredible duress
our future adversaries are not going to
give us that luxury in fact they are
hell-bent on getting ai putin has said
he who gets it first
wins um to be able to make the most
rapid decision-making
be the most influential in the
information space etc going forward
and so we need to embrace this and then
write that ragged edge up to
do you hand the keys to the car to
enable the ai to take the shot or not
and that is the crux of debate
but i think you should run you know well
up to that before you turn over trigger
uh and then embrace the situations the
one-offs where
it might be advantageous to say yep in
those sort of scenarios
ai ai must you know being able to take
the shot or we will
or it may be an existential you know
threat for you know that you that you
will rule the day you won't have the
chance to rule the day you'll be gone
what's so fascinating to me is there's
kind of like how effective is the
technology
how would we apply it and then
ultimately how do we almost go through
the governance of the technology right
who gets to take the shot
is there a human override do we trust
the software how accurate is it what's
the efficacy all that kind of stuff
um another technology offer too that and
there's an event that i'd encourage
everybody to get online and look at
uh darpa uh you know you know who's
enabled some incredible technology into
our force
recently uh hosted a dogfight uh you
know uh
event with the air force and the air
force's credit they signed up and said
okay
we're gonna let you throw an unmanned ai
enabled
uh capability against our very best
think of nellis
guys you know uh top gun kind of guys
and it almost
it uh it had me torn because you had you
watched an incredibly talented
human being pilot literally perplexed by
uh an ai enabled uh craft that beat them
five out of five times and you could see
this you can find this on
on youtube uh it's it's at the end of
the session so if you want to cut to the
chase
for that uh that video um and and so
the takeaways were clear man you know
this ai
in in a dogfight scenario if we think
we're going to be in those kind of
scenarios in the future
is a considerable technology what what i
was uh
i should have been surprised because
human nature on the backside was
essentially the pilot lobby that came on
said whoa
not ready for prime time and by the way
that that
uh craft was doing suicidal tactics
to get the win and you're saying stop
you know stop for a moment and think
what you just said the ai
does not know fear the ai does not know
fatigue
the end and and i hate doing this to
whether it's
fighter jockeys or aircraft carrier
captains and all
is to pose the next hard question of
okay i got it that you're
you're you know you're beholden to your
current your current craft
your current platform do you want your
kid
to go up against an ai airplane
missiles whatever it might be in the
future with the technology that we're
leveraging now and the answer is clearly
not
then when are you going to do that leap
ahead uh to you know to have that
capability where we're going to reduce
the threat which is kind of a uh you
know
an american ideal uh but also be at the
fore of
of this technology and and folks have
used the new the nuclear analogy
and i i agree it is it is part and
parcel to
you know the seminal moment of the
development of nuclear weapons um and we
should be
thinking about it as as aggressively um
you know and
and and solving it not get caught up in
the policy
conundrums etc that will that will
presage actual discussions
yeah something related to kind of the ai
machine learning computer vision
uh the drones etc it's just robotics in
general and it feels like there's a big
push right now where people are saying
well why are we risking human life let's
just send the uh the robot army out and
you know we'll kind of trot them out and
they'll do a great job and uh hopefully
they don't turn against us
kind of what's the the evaluation of
where we are on the robotic side
unfortunately again uh for every place
you trot out
robots into solution or unmanned as a
solution there is a man lobby that's
you know hold on for dear life against
that and you think of the number of
things that have changed over time where
yeah i i believe it's inevitable but you
gotta you gotta overcome that obstacle
but i think the most constructive way to
get at this in the future and i'm hoping
the armed forces embrace this is
simulation
and or testing where you literally say
hey i'm going out to the national
training center or the mojave or
wherever it might be
come fight me and we we invite you know
leading-edge technology companies come
in with
all the widgets and gadgets and tech and
and kick our ass i mean literally free
play
um show us where our vulnerabilities are
so that we have that again seminal
moment to to to adapt and and go forward
too much of it i mean the darpa uh uh
situation i
described was extraordinary and that
they took the gloves off it was a
it was a dog fight and the air force you
know uh got
was beaten badly um but we didn't
you know come on the backside and say
okay how do we get that company or that
technology
into the force as soon as possible so i
think i think
you know the department needs to embrace
uh and not chase technology that was one
of the
lessons we learned at socom that you can
chase technology everywhere in the
valley in austin in boston
carnegie mellon you name it you'll chase
forever you'll be chasing individual
companies too by the way
or you flip the paradigm and bring them
under the tent
bring companies on the tent most mostly
venture capitalist companies i think are
are really powerful and that they have a
broad array of portfolio companies that
you know hey anybody interested in this
good here's here's the
opportunity the environment to get in
and and help
you know help the uh our national
security the the google experience with
maven
i thought was really cathartic for you
know for
for dod because you hear you had the
google workforce at least a portion of
it saying whoa whoa we don't want
anything to do with you know drone
warfare and that this sort of national
defense get us out of this and google
they didn't they people have mistakenly
said they
bought they complete their contract they
just didn't go on to the next phase it
was picked up
by somebody else interestingly who's
back in business more
you know adamantly than ever google in
the form of eric schmidt and others
saying
hey we had that moment we've had a
chance to chat amongst ourselves we will
always have a portion of our people that
don't want to do this
um but they're back in but more
importantly in the wake of that
i can't count the number number of
companies both startups and established
companies
who are anxious to help the department
they want in they want to be able to you
know to
to help us uh going forward um the
difficulty is
you know the devil's in the details on
how how they get under the tent and get
integrated but
but there's not any shortage of of
companies that want to be involved in in
solving these wicked problems yeah when
we talk about innovation uh kind of on
the battlefield and within the military
one of my favorite stories is and
i don't know exactly how accurate every
single detail here is but the general
story is that the
rhino for those that don't know is a uh
it's basically a
a box that has got a uh a set of um
heat that comes out of it uh and it's
extended out in front of vehicles and
and it's there
to uh kind of defeat uh infrared type
ieds so basically rather than have the
engine block be the trigger for an ied
and kind of put human life at risk
this is a box that literally just
extends the heat signature
out in front of the vehicle and the
story that i had heard when i was
deployed was basically a very young
soldier came up with the idea by putting
spark plugs inside of like ammo box and
put it on the front of his vehicle and
next thing you know the military said
hey that's a great idea and let's kind
of
you know get that rolled out as fast as
we can to save as many lives as possible
and uh you know regardless of the
accuracy of the individual details
there is this debate between can the
innovation come from you know people who
are actually in uniform who have the
experiences and kind of have the ground
truth and knowledge
versus uh folks who have the technology
experience and they can come look at the
problem set and then develop the uh the
solutions
what was your experience um kind of in
the military in terms of innovation
happening
internal versus external and how do you
kind of look at the balance between
those two things
moving forward yeah i would be suspect
of any initiative that was started at
the higher level
um and the classic that was before my
time here at socom
that people tried out was called the the
special operations handgun
and as you might imagine by the end of
the day this thing looked like the rube
goldberg
uh you know hubble telescope of pistols
that you could never use in
in you know in combat but it was
designed by this headquarters instead of
and and i i think we try we certainly
know we try to we don't always stay true
to
mating operators practitioners
you know uh you know of the trade
at the tactical level with our with that
you know the technologists the
acquisition experts to really get that
symbiosis for
you know for uh technological
development the harder part though and i
mentioned earlier is
with all that going and socom is 75 000
strong across the planet a lot of great
uh individual problem solving going on
how do you identify
leading edge technology tactics
techniques and procedures as you and i
would call back in the day
and say okay that that's where we need
to invest
and i provide the resources obviously um
to what
you know to what scale and for how much
for how long
uh to to bring it into the force um and
so i
you've got that conundrum of the higher
headquarters with the with the resources
and with the budgetary requirements and
the the problem solving
happening at the tactical level how do
you how do you mesh it
i i i used to use this technique at
socom
and it would drive some people nuts and
i didn't do it to do
to drive them nuts um and some would
call it the old directed telescope but
on any given day and i tried to get away
from my headquarters
as much as possible i didn't like
sitting in an office and we had people
in 80 different countries around the
world a lot of them in harm's way
so i spent a lot of time on the road but
i couldn't always be there
so in the morning if i read a situation
report that said hey pomp and his guys
yesterday
just crushed it in this and when i say
crush people always think i'm saying
kinetic
it could have been the greatest
humanitarian assistance effort whatever
but as i got that report and said wow
that was great can we reach out and talk
to them and i don't want
anybody in their chain of command in
between it's going to be just like i'm
visiting them in
you pick the location again that's the
part that a lot of people didn't like
but i say just imagine if i were on the
road i'd get that opportunity
and i'd sit down with our our teammates
and say hey
i read last night you did this please
give me more on it and my star major
would sit there with me a great former
delta operator and we'd sit
and one it was selfish because we would
get the
buzz of man what you know these are our
teammates don't you love being part of
this organization
but i would always have this one
question loaded for them at the end of
the day
and say hey is there anything i can do
from up here on
mount olympus mount socom to help you do
your job better in the future
and every decent team later had that
that answer ready
oh just in case you might ask and it
would and barely be
if i only had the calculator or if i had
these authorities or if i had whatever
and so i'd say good have you asked have
you pushed that request officially up
through the you know through the system
oh yes sir three bags full i said okay
great i will get back to you you know
you uh monkey transfer i've got this now
i'll get back to you
and so we'd meet after that session i'd
have my staff in there and say okay
team x on the ground wherever says they
need this thing
the request is out there officially
somewhere find it and we would find it
at one of our many
too many intermediate headquarters stuck
with a lot of well-meaning people who
were trying to move the rock uphill but
didn't have the wherewithal to do it
and i used to joke that hey jeff bezos
is not running amazon like this
he is running a flat enough situation
awareness
organization that he knows the pacing
items
uh for his organization and and he's
able to shift resources
and and so i i would try to get our
headquarters both my headquarters at the
macro level
not to sit back wondering what the men
need today or the men men and women out
there need today
and those at the tip of the spear to
crush that space down so we actually
could
provide the resources necessary we did
not and i would tell my guys
as many painful sessions as i had at
congress you know testifying in front of
mccain and others
we never lacked the resources for what
we needed to do
i mean i had a 13 billion dollar budget
that was just our operating you know our
our annual budget we could get the
resources
and more if we needed it all i need to
do is be able to present that here's the
wicked problem and i don't have the
resources for it and i can't
cross-level internally so um i was
disappointed that we
had our own bureaucratic challenges even
in a force that was
considered to be pretty agile yeah one
of the things that you're talking about
here is kind of just the
efficacy i think that a lot of these
technology firms have had right they
obviously they grow because they're
efficient both in communication
operations and and the production of
whatever the the line of business
is that they're in um what we've seen in
silicon valley specifically you
mentioned a little bit uh with kind of
the google situation is
a fairly polarized uh population of
of workers right so there's some people
who say uh i want nothing to do with
helping the united states and and kind
of our defense operations uh i disagree
with that body of
uh work and so uh if the company i work
at does that i'm going to
you know on the light and uh basically
protest it in some form or fashion or
on the kind of more aggressive end i'm
literally going to quit my job and go
somewhere else
uh but there's also another group of
people and this is kind of the
palanteers and the anderls and a number
of other technologists who say no listen
if
we do not use technology to protect our
country to
give that capability to our war fighters
then we actually are
doing ourselves a disservice and so i'm
going to go build a company i'm going to
go work within
kind of government and defense and i'm
gonna go kind of do my part
how do you think we get um kind of a
little bit
more of a centrist view right so rather
than have kind of that polarized
um kind of divisiveness if you will how
do we start to
get folks to understand that the public
and private sector can work together
kind of do the right things but it's
also not an unchecked power for the
the public sector and that there is uh
kind of the ethical conversation
happening around technology
and some of the other concerns that they
may have yeah i i actually think there's
an over emphasis
on this small uh group that is adamantly
opposed to
to you know to do anything that uh that
aligns them with national defense
uh and or going to war and i i get i
mean you can go back to the first point
nobody more opposed to going to war than
me um but
you know sometimes it finds you and
whether or not you want it
uh there's a there's a more eloquent
quote that goes with that that you're
aware of
um so um i think the
the best capture of this that i've read
consumed over the last couple years trey
stevens did an editorial
that talks to your point that you might
not want to do this but our adversaries
are actually going in this direction
again some don't think we have any
adversaries out there i'd love to live
in their
netherworld um but um so
it's a compelling discussion that please
understand the nature of
the security concerns for the country
you live in and i got it the most these
companies are global
but you know you if you're if you put
your marker down in san jose or
austin or wherever it is you know uh you
know there's an expectation there and
i'm not
i'm not wrapping myself up in
nationalism either here
but it's it's more of a practical thing
but but the the bigger challenge
and what's interesting my experience
over the last two years has been to
uh meet companies that had no intention
by design to compete or to provide
solutions in the national security space
but their technology is so uh compelling
um that in discussions we've said you
know this could be integrated
in the national security have you
thought about that in a couple cases i
got immediate pushback of whoa that
wasn't
our founders vision but then they come
back a couple weeks later and say hey
we actually would like to do things for
the government how do we get in that
space
um and there begins the journey so um
again how do we you know how many times
have you and i read that the paradigm
is flipped dod it used to be
the center of gravity for a lot of
technological development the internet
blah blah blah
the paradigm's completely flipped it's
no longer the locus of all that there's
some good innovation going on in dod the
majority of it is in the private sector
how do you how do you uh establish the
dialogue and the venues
to match you know match the two as
constructively as possible going forward
i have not i mean i would be very
concerned if i were i was
bouncing off a lot of companies that
were no at hello i don't want any part
of this
i i am experiencing the exact opposite
that uh one they're
they're appreciative of the national
security challenges and concerns now and
in the future
uh they want to be more informed about
it and the majority of them who have
technology that's that's apropos to it
are interested in how do i how do i help
how do i how do i
and of course there's the pragmatic
aspect of of
making them making a dime or two on that
but that's not where the money is
that's part of the problem is uh you
know the companies that are successful
for the most part
have serious serious private sector
success
and they and they'll realize that you
know the government's success will be
less
you know less beneficial to them but
they they want to be in that space
absolutely my friend bill perkins had a
great question on twitter where he asked
kind of in your opinion uh today what
are the three
greatest threats to america right are
they are they
nation states are they technologies just
when you hear that what are kind of your
reactions to the three greatest threats
you know we wrestle with this all the
time so um and
and um interestingly the same
five threats that are uh that are
captured right now with the new
administration
are the same five threats that uh four
years ago
were presented to a different
administration so in terms of nation
states or variety logical threats out
there
um everybody knows your kind of road if
your national security is china russia
north
korea iran and violent extremism that
was a way of describing you know the
islamic phenomenon that we were dealing
with at the time
um i i think and we ironically back then
we
we listed those pretty forcefully in in
documents
to try to get us uh more balance from
our
counter and counter terrorist
counterinsurgent effort in the middle
east
on to china as a at least a budding
adversary and four years ago our
national policy our stated national
policy
was to not refer to china as an
adversary that was
that was the administration that uh
president biden served in before
i think we've had that bipartisan uh you
know
uh acknowledgement that if they're not
an adversary they're sure
behaving in an adversarial fashion uh
and
if you read their literature they do
believe xi jinping and others
do believe that there is going to be a
meeting engagement sometime down the
road here
uh where it won't be ships passing in
the night kind of kind of evolution
and and it may not be peaceful that's
where i mean it
was just to read what what uh the ccp is
saying about
where they see themselves now and in the
future so
i do see china it's irresistible um
you just have to read the first chapter
of graham allison's book just to
understand the demographics and the
magnitude of the economy you know
this is not something the u.s can take
on motto amano
it is it is you know an incredible uh
challenge from from that standpoint so
we need you know the point being we need
partners we need
uh and i read something i think in the
economics the other day the good news is
and the western world is still you know
60 of of the
you know the gdp so you do have leverage
now unless you let it
wane and and and and die off so i think
china's out there
russia is not going away and
unfortunately you're seeing it now with
navalny
is you know the joke which i don't think
was said jokingly
a couple years ago and continues to play
out is that putin is not going to go out
par you know uh
vertical um so you've you've got the
power personalities whether it's xi
jinping
uh putin and others and uh kju and in
north korea
these personalities uh that are
variables that you just have to consider
uh you know will will be disruptive
going forward so china and russia kind
of in combination because they're
existential threats
and then you know people think i'm being
too fluffy now but i would go on to two
venues
uh that i'm concerned without the
specific threat one is space
and i saw the to do on twitter today uh
disparaging space force and all
you know the news flash without getting
into classified levels of discussion is
we are terribly keep you awake at night
kind of vulnerable
in space right now we're way behind
um so if it so if you like and if you're
beholden
as we are from a national defense
standpoint on
satellite-enabled communications expect
that to be the first lights out
shot fired in a future conflict unless
we start you know start stepping up the
plate and understanding that venue
and then the other part that's pertinent
to that is the information space and
that sounds really fluffy
but right now the amount of
disinformation that is running around
the world
um ends you know again on a previous
podcast someone was talking about
information anxiety well there better be
information anxiety because
you know who knows what's factual in
this day and age to
base your decisions on but we have to
sort through that
yeah so i know that there's um a lot of
sensitivities here so just kind of
whatever you're allowed to say but i
want to go a little bit deeper on the
whole idea of space and
uh obviously the idea of a space force
and all of that i think people
uh immediately jump to oh what are we
going to do protect ourselves from the
aliens right or some kind of
some uh you know outrageous kind of uh
edge case type situation but really what
you're talking about here is
uh one there's a lot more communication
infrastructure there's a lot of
companies that are trying to do
multi-planetary travel or they're trying
to do now even
space manufacturing you know look at
somebody like varda there's all sorts of
different technologies whether it's
reusable rockets
or some sort of 3d printed rockets you
just kind of go in the line there's a
lot of innovation happening here
and most of that is happening in the
western world but when you talk about
kind of the vulnerabilities
in space kind of just from a very high
level like what exactly does that mean
and so for people at home who are
thinking about
oh a space force like why is that
important and kind of how do you just
think of
space as a you know maybe a battlefield
that uh isn't necessarily contentious
today but could become contentious in
the future
yeah i think the space force has been
cathartic
uh and it has woken us up from this
naive dream state assumption whatever it
might be
that space will not be an area not be a
contested area that somehow that was
going to be off limits
we're not going to do bad things up
there it'll be
restricted to normal domains of land sea
air etc and cyber
wrong wrong bad assumption flawed uh and
and has been proven to be flawed so
without even going into classified stuff
you know just look at open source on uh
what the chinese and the russians have
already put up there
that is not intended to be good it's not
intended to
play nicely with others um and ask
yourself
okay what have we done to protect
ourselves much less
to balance you know that playing field
there and so i think
uh your space force will help us focus
on that i don't think that
space force was um
sufficiently birthed um with enough
of its own wherewithal it's still way
too
tied to the air force now you can argue
that it was part of the air force before
uh but but both from a process and a
kind of a you know a linkage uh
budgetary etc it's still
very much a kind of an air force baby
even even as
listed as a separate department um or a
separate service
um it it's it's not free it's not
running free
yet i hope i hope it will eventually but
i think i think it's some an area that
we absolutely
have to have this discussion this honest
discussion why do we you know it's
today in twitter it's still a little too
political on
was this just a wild idea from the
previous administration
hopefully people will pull up and say
okay do we need to compete up there
the answer is yes how what's the best
way to do it whether establishing
another service and a
combatant command was the way to do it
you can you could
cut that thing every which way and come
up with other solutions but we
absolutely need to compete so i want to
go from space and kind of bring it just
domestically
uh over the last couple of weeks we
obviously had a whole bunch of
kind of concerns and then also a couple
of different events one that
kept coming up on twitter was
specifically was around the
the capitol building um and some of the
activities there
i know you've got some thoughts just on
uh kind of the military's role
in a lot of domestic activities right so
that's kind of serving as one exact
example but maybe talk just a little bit
about
how you see um soldiers and other
military members and kind of their role
uh both foreign and domestic and kind of
how that's evolving or becoming
a bigger focus or more importance uh in
their kind of day-to-day
operations yeah what a i mean really
it's hard to believe that for me still
that that
is in the wake of our recent history
that the whole events of 6 january
um you know for those who are not
familiar with the military and there
will be a few that listen to your
podcast i mean
we enjoy incredible support from the
american public and we should never take
it for granted
i i have actually the older i've gotten
the more sentimental i feel for vietnam
veterans
who who did what their country asked
them to do and were treated
like crap when they came back home my
generation has never had that experience
we've always had yellow ribbons around
trees we've always said thank you for
your service everywhere you go
as a socon commander you know the most
rewarding thing i do now in the private
sector
is i'm the chairman for a non-profit
uh that sends our gold star kids the
children's of our surviving
of our fallen warriors our teammates uh
to college full rides we put 41 into
college this last year we put 400 so far
800 to go but that's all enabled by
great american benef
benefactor or benefactors out there who
give us the wherewithal to do that so we
we're very lucky
now i say that acknowledging that i
don't think most of america has any idea
what we do
on a daily basis they know they do know
that 700 billion dollars is spent on
on our armed forces every year that's a
big big budget
and but when you start checking down the
the list of what that budget buys
you know aircraft carriers at 13 to 15
billion dollars a pop
f-35s etc etc nuclear triad that keeps
you safe against
other nuclear threats it ain't cheap to
you know to have this you know keep this
country safe against all threats
we could do it better we could do it a
lot more efficiently uh there's a lot of
waste in our in our budget but
um it is what it is but in
in that milieu uh and in the context of
hey we've been in combat for the last 20
years and some people wonder why
we're still there uh we're about keeping
the country safe
we are also for the unacquainted a great
reflection
on the american public i mean forced uh
social experiments as their so-called
have have occurred in the military long
before they've ever
been manifest in in uh you know in our
society and you serve
you know with the you know the penn
state national guard there i mean
we we serve with people from every walk
of life
every you know every persuasion and
and whether or not you liked him
personally you got along
on team america and did your job and and
and
i think we're all better better uh
better from that exposure you know we
were
exposed to people from other places the
united states other thoughts and
and and uh and everything that goes with
it and it and it's it's one of the more
rewarding things
um but we're not a special interest
group and it really annoys me that
too many politicians want to leverage
the military as a special interest group
i mean i don't know how what your
experience was we never talked politics
when i was in the military
it was something you didn't care it was
much like
you know uh sexual orientation you
didn't didn't care
um color of your skin didn't care um we
still had some hangouts we still have
some people that didn't quite get the
message
um and needed to be brought along or
moved out of the service um but we all
you know we all accepted those those
differences so
we're not a special interest group um
that has really come to play this last
year in terms of what what's the
military's role
in domestic uh disputes and
you know what for people to use charged
language like civil war
and things like that and we've had a
civil war you know do you do your
homework do your you know
do do some studies here i mean the thing
that almost ripped us apart 140 years
ago 160 years ago
uh we we lived at you know we 180 years
i guess public math
um yeah we've lived that hard we don't
need to relearn that lesson
um but where it came to the almost
tipping point was
should our military have some role in
these domestic disputes
and here's where again a very charged
discussion but but
something that is absolutely being
reinforced in the military
is every one of us uh whether officer
enlisted
swears an oath to the constitution of
the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic that's not a
personal oath to anybody that's not even
an oath to the flag for all those that
want to wrap themselves
up that's a that's a a commitment to our
constitution
and to the aspirational goals that were
listed there and people can disparage
the constitution
about being written by a bunch of white
slave owners yes it absolutely was
you know shame on them that they could
write a document and not live it at the
time
but it was to push us on this ark to be
that
that shiny beacon on the hill and you
know people have disparaged when i've
used that term i said hey that's not
something america
i think sought to be the shiny beacon on
the hill but when i
when i have been in dozens and dozens of
countries especially
towards the end of my uh tenure as a
four-star
i can't count the number of times i
would sit down with heads of states
or heads of defense and they always had
some complaint about the united states
there would always be something that oh
you americans you did this wrong it
usually had something to do with their
country some decision we made or
whatever
but in every case universally and there
was not a single exception
the last message they would ask me to
take back home to our leadership was
please stay in the lead please stay
involved
because warts and all your country
provides a sanity a balance to this
wacky world out there
and that's not to say you know we're the
greatest country in the world or you
know
where we don't have our own problems we
just demonstrated that
you know terribly over the last you know
year or so um
but but the world sounds pretty honors
here
is kind of depending on us to to provide
some
semblance of leadership going forward um
and it's it's something that was part of
our
our development part of this great
experiment that we live in again there
are a ton of people in the united states
that think
i didn't sign up for that okay you go
you probably need to go outside
and look back in every once in a while
and get you'll get appreciation for that
my best buzz comes from eastern european
countries
where a guy my age lived for three
decades
under soviet oppression and they are
they are just so jazzed with being
liberated it's not funny
um and to touch that but it gives you a
buzz of whoa what that spark is
is something special and we've we've
forgotten it
absolutely is there any idea that what
we can do to
um kind of just better educate i think
or inform
folks here in the united states uh who
maybe aren't fortunate enough to
travel to other parts of the world and
kind of see it firsthand is it just
telling more of these stories is it uh
somehow trying to take people from
different backgrounds and experiences
and get them together so that they can
learn from each other
just any thoughts in terms of how do we
almost create more of the empathy and
really recognize i think some of the
advantages that the country has
both from a defense standpoint but also
kind of from a democratic and societal
standpoint
yeah a lot of ways it could happen but
people need to be open
to the thought i mean uh you know what
if we picked this scab the last year
that every one of us
came from somewhere else you know you
weren't a native here you know you
weren't a native uh you know for the
most
other than that select few who were
natives here um
and uh and can you reflect on that at
all that you they all came from
somewhere else
in the tech circles you know even with
with the vaccination
you know the number of uh you know
immigrants who were integral to solving
that problem who proudly
call themselves americans now and again
i i work with a bunch of folks who are
either
uh you know first generation expats or
the sons and daughters of
expats um and you get a buzz from them
you i mean that they
really appreciate warts and all you know
what what what we're about and
they're actually more offended when we
when we when we lose that
that direction that that vector um so
those kind of exposure but
i do think you just we have to cut
through uh
you know just the the visceral
opposition
to we're not the world's policemen we're
not the world's
i what was it what's the sporting guys
commentary i didn't i didn't sign up to
be a role model yeah
charles barkley i'm not a role model
he's actually a pretty damn good role
model these days you know so
charles has uh has evolved over time
but you know but there are a lot of
people that don't think hey
that's not that's not the essence the
united states i'm not we don't have to
do that and we don't have to
i just don't like to think of what might
happen if we don't
i tend to agree i want to talk a little
bit about your transition out of the
military
uh you're spending much more time in the
private sector uh you talked a little
bit about the uh the nonprofit work
you're doing but
also you're spending time uh with lux
capital and a number of
kind of venture-backed companies maybe
just talk a little bit as to you know as
you were transitioning out what were you
looking to do
uh why lux and then kind of what you're
doing on a day-to-day basis with them
yeah um again i'm blessed by opportunity
so
um part of our problem in the military
and i'm i'm a representative and
this is not a pity party for a retired
general officer because and i know that
will come up
is none of us is thinking about life
after for the most part
yeah some of them aren't some people
come in the military as a springboard to
go elsewhere
but a great number of us are thriving in
the moment
we're laser focused on what we're doing
our noses to the grindstone
and then what do you know it's time to
retire it's time to get out and uh
some have thought about it uh we don't
adequately prepare people to get out um
my seminal moment was sitting down with
in a space of a week with a retiring
colonel
and a retiring sergeant major from socom
and realizing that both of them
had short-sheeted themselves in terms of
transition time
and that partly that's on us because we
say oh it's about a two year process to
you know to retire and leave the service
yet we let them work themselves up to
the last day we haven't hired their
replacement to force them into that
that transition mode and give you time
you know go go figure out what you want
to do when you grow up
so um i entered into that you know that
transition kind of same way of
boy i wonder what i'm going to do when i
get out i absolutely did not want to go
work for one of the defense
establishment entities um which
interesting you know for those who are
not acquainted we're actually precluded
we're putting a two-year timeout which
is a good thing
uh as retired general officers from
selling anything back to the department
of defense
i think that's that's that's good um it
should apply to other
agencies and entities out there which it
does it doesn't necessarily apply to
them
but it puts us in time out so that kind
of forcefully had me
thinking what i want to do besides this
um and then i was presented some
opportunities in both
venture capital uh and artificial
intelligence which fascinates me again
i'm um
um you may be humored uh my advantage to
speaking with someone like you today and
i and i get a buzz out of that as much
as i get a buzz out of talking
to newly liberated uh you know guys my
age in eastern europe
is i have sons your age so uh they keep
me
you know kind of what i said tragically
hip uh but there's a good example
i was testifying in front of the senate
armed services one day
my last testimony and uh a senator asked
a ques a softball question about
uh the importance of a.i and do you
think it's
you know do you think it's important and
where are we and
i think it's transformational and
important should lead a revolution in
how we do things um
so i asked my cohort in crime paul
nakasoni who's the
brilliant cybercom nsa uh chief i said
can i answer this question
and i said i'm a huge uh zealot for ai
i think we're moving way too slowly um
and i'm concerned
i wasn't five minutes off the floor and
if you guys ever watch c-span it's a lot
of theater there's a lot of it's it's
it's
for it's for the consuming american
public out there
not it's not very substantive the better
sessions are in separate offices or
private offices
but i was five minutes off the floor of
the senate and my youngest son who's
meaning me
his sarcasm puts me to shame texts me
and he said
hey dad if you're a zealot for ai i'm
steve jobs and uh
because he knows i have difficulty
making my my my phone work
but the point being you know it's
something that my generation needs to
appreciate we're not we're not digital
you know we're digital voyagers we're
not we're not we weren't
you know uh you know brought up in it
and and it is
the way of the world now so uh too many
uh my disappointment in the private
sector
i'm amazed the number of companies i
bounce into where uh
seniors you know uh what did mcafee and
jofson call the hippo syndrome the
highest paid person's opinion
they're in that corner office and they
give the big hand way for ai
but it's please don't make me wrestle
with that because i'll show you how
stupid i am with it you know that i'm
just not intellectual about that but
that's the point
get intellectual get you know get to
understand it and and
too many companies just won't it's it's
the five year out problem i don't have
to deal with it
and somebody else will pick it up on
their watch yeah
it's absolutely fascinating to uh to
hear um
you know your son texts you right and uh
and it always reminds us that uh there's
more to learn
there's some there's kind of always some
other uh other angle
um when it comes to the companies that
you're helping today
through through lux and some of the work
there are there specific things that
uh you try to position yourself in terms
of being able to be helpful to the
companies
is it uh leadership which obviously
you've got a plethora of
uh is it uh kind of defense uh in some
of the uh the mental models and and
the ways to navigate that space and kind
of some of the problem sets
is it more so from a technology
standpoint capital raising
just how do you think of yourself you
know as you interact with uh with
founders of these businesses in terms of
being able to be helpful
while also learning from them at the
same time yeah again i'm i'm very
grateful and thankful that
that i've been hired on uh in various
capacities
for some of what you describe you know
strategic
insight leadership uh
things like that a hope for that i can
keep pace technologically
and that's where i i wrestle as hard as
i can up i'll sit through some of that
you mentioned lux i'll sit through some
of the luck sessions
and uh you know one of my sons is
endeavoring to
go to med school here and i'll say okay
here's the topic for today
and my head hurts so you know hard right
now
because we have the experts there who
who oh
you know literary phds on the subject
and you know i'm not
you know i'm not um but but it's it's
just
selfishly um it's it's fascinating that
because
you know i know i you know uh literally
i can't create any more
creases in my gray space but something's
making some room some of that ram is
getting ejected and something else is
being inserted there to make me
uh think more uh about the future but i
think the other part too and i
i try to i'm in fact i'm more
conscientious about this now
unfortunately than i was during my 40
years to my point earlier that
a great great slice of america has no
idea about their military
uh i want to make sure that they can you
know point to somebody
hey i know somebody in the military and
they walk and talk just like we do
they have the same uh you know
challenges same
different perspective whatever it might
be but just so that we're not you know
left in this little cocoon of i love my
military i can't name one person
you know other than my distant cousin
who served there um so i try and break
down that as much as i can as well to
make sure they understand
their military you know their their
national security challenges as as some
of these things come to play
um so i'm again i feel uh grateful that
i have the opportunity
to uh you know to participate in that
regard and then
the tech part i mean it just the amazing
world of technological development right
now to being a company that is
you know post seed uh not you know not
not too far down the road uh boy i mean
i
i look forward to every monday when we
have our sessions where it's
you know get ready to scribble and
google a bunch of stuff you've never
heard of before
uh and and again to the you know
credit to the leadership there they want
to know my opinion and
if i don't and i one of the one things
i've provided to you know to some
leadership
sessions it's okay to say i don't know
in fact that's a really powerful
statement sometimes
and when you're dealing with a wicked
problem i don't know i don't know
let's let's sort let's sort through this
together i encourage people don't make
that your default you will look like a
dumb ass eventually
but i don't know as an okay commentary
and often i will come back
you know to these discussions say who i
don't know about that technology or that
team or whatever might you because we
look at it from a couple tiered optic
but just to be part of that discussion i
mean it can't help but make you blossom
um in terms of the forever learning
approach that
certainly compels me absolutely you've
got a
40 years or so of of great leadership
experience and one of the
the organizations in the world that's
known for a great leadership you've
probably been to
more leadership schools training and
real world experiences than
most could ever dream of when you sit
down with a
ceo a founder what are some of the
lessons that you really try to kind of
hammer home on the leadership front
whether they're actual kind of
tactics and techniques or just more so
kind of philosophical
mantras that you think are important for
uh for founders of organizations and
leaders of those organizations to kind
of embody and take away from the
conversation
you know i am absolutely guilty of uh
late life development for actually
having sat down to acknowledge
uh the extraordinary leadership
experience that i've had i mean i
um if anything early on i kept book
unofficial book
on what not to do i'm not gonna do that
that's a terrible example not going to
so you made that mental check
to reinforce the good luck because that
that was the aberration those were the
one-offs
but they were they're out there i mean
and i think there's some good
uh learning involved with that but it
wasn't until much
later in life that i just had that duh
moment of man
i i need to sit down and and put my
thoughts together my experiences
together my insights
gain from other people you know no
credit to myself here
and whether it's you know it's there's a
whole compendium of leadership
uh perspectives that i've put together i
don't know what i'm going to do with it
someday and
and i i often share them liberally with
with audiences
when they're asked they ask me to speak
about leadership but two so one thing i
offer to folks is especially senior
folks have you sat down and
reflected on leadership what you you
know there's there's tones written about
it
what's your personal experience what's
really resonated with you it's normally
the same sort of things that the simon
cynics of the world will try it out that
are
yep uh that's that's intuitive but he at
least took the time to
write them down and and present them
back to us um
but the two areas that i think are
intuitive that
that get too much of a hand wave and one
is you know and at the mantra i used to
try because i am terrible i mean this
was a shortcoming for me
that i thought i knew the answer before
the discussion even started or
or i didn't need to wade through some
discussion
is and i forgot to impart it to me but
are you listening or you or are you just
waiting to talk
and i try and let that little mantra
play on my shoulder all the time that
oh hang in there there's something here
you know just let's just hold on you
don't have every answer or otherwise you
wouldn't be here
and the other one that i hear too often
is the need for
caring leadership but but my point and
offered to people that if you don't if
you don't know
your people you can't care for them and
the best example that was trotted out to
me
um and i think it was michelle flournoy
when she was speaking when i was working
at the cia
she mentioned that in one of her uh
introductory counseling sessions for a
company and i think this was played to
her but
it could have been something that she
experienced through somebody else but as
the typical you know senior supported
uh whatever relationship you want to uh
think of here
as they did the initial counseling um
it's often really perfunctory of hey
pomp what's up you know what's important
to you
you know okay good get get out there and
you'll get him killer
um and in this case the individual said
um
what's important to you but i'm going to
ask i want i want to hear something
substantive
i want to know the weekly activity that
come hell or high water you want to
attend outside of work that's important
to you and in this case it was
your son's baseball game uh daughter's
soccer what whatever it might have been
you know
piano lessons whatever boy you know i i
i'm really proud of the way my kids
develop in this regard or my
here's my personal thing that i'd like
to do and that was the contract right
from the beginning from that boss to
that individual of okay good
tuesday when you say that happens
tuesday at
five o'clock in the afternoon that's
sacred you never have to come ask me
about that
that's on the calendar for you to be
there now you know
i'm going to work you to death and we'll
be busy as hell but you've got that
squared away and by the way if there's
other important stuff like that
it's on you you need to tell me don't
don't let that you know sit on you
but to me it kind of cracked through
that veneer of oh caring leadership and
knowing your people
you got to know them you literally uh
the one i've trotted out
um and much what i appreciate what you
do you know
in twitter and other people is you make
us think but the one experience that i
tried out that was
really i mean i just changed the way i
see things is uh at one point in time i
asked my guys
i was a big fan of anthony bourdain and
i asked my guys
uh i think i was when i was a jsoc
commander i could never make it happen
but i said hey guys he is everywhere i
want to be and he and i can't go he's in
libya
at the after the fall of moamar he's in
iran you know hanging around in tehran i
can't go there
he's you picked a place and i said i'd
see if bourdain will meet with me just
whimsically see if bourdain will meet
with me
well i didn't realize that bourdain is a
student of vietnam or was a student of
vietnam
a great episode is when he meets obama
in downtown hanoi which is
to me oh i mean powerful um
and uh so he agreed to meet with me in a
restaurant up off columbus circle in new
york
and we had three hours of rolling
conversation i joked we both spoke
jersey
although he would summer over in paris
or france i didn't summer over in paris
my family
wasn't of that uh you know that uh kind
of altitude but um
but we it was a rambling conversation
all over the map and i and i walked away
uh thinking man this guy's got it
together as more than i thought he had
it on tv
and what i liked about him is he made
you think he didn't have to agree with
everything he said
but he made you think well as well know
anthony bourdain killed himself about
two months later
and what struck me at the time is
again back to this caring leadership is
everyone i
actually wrote up wrote up a description
on facebook of the meandering
conversation we had
um but at the end what someone had
imparted to me
in the wake of that was hey every one of
us is wrestling with a demon that nobody
else knows about
and my point being and i've my star
major and i were
adamant about this with our with our
guys especially as we dealt with
tough subjects like suicide etc that
everybody you meet and touch every day
is struggling with something i don't
care how happy they are
every person you know has a challenge
they're dealing with
how do we relate that to each other or
do we just continue the rat race of
you know daily existence until you
wonder whoa johnny just did something or
jane
went sideways and almost invariably we
could see that coming but nobody
took a time out and said how you doing
or or you know where can we help you
where can we
you know alleviate your burden here so
it's it's to me it's
that that's the aspect of leadership
that that is under emphasize that you
you can play a pivotal role if you're
inclined to
yeah i think it's fantastic and it
really is the difference between kind of
the academic exercise of leadership
right uh
of kind of hey i'm in charge or i'm
going to influence you to do something
but once you actually kind of put it
into practice and understand that
it's not as easy as maybe the books say
uh there's a lot of good principles in
there but you still have to understand
people
and we started off the conversation with
uh you know some of the best technology
on the battlefield as people
uh same thing here in terms of
leadership before we wrap up i always
ask everybody the same three questions
and i'm uh
really looking forward to your answers
because i think you're gonna have a
unique perspective
um you're one of probably the most
well-read people that i know
what is the most important book that
you've ever read whether it's importance
in terms of just changing your world
view or informing it
or just personal impact on you when you
hear what's the most important book what
comes to mind geez
i mean i've got my my library is right
here next to me
uh and i and i continually have people
throw things at me that are you know one
better than the last thing i read
um you know one of the guys i worked
through for and i don't know why i
missed it but uh send me shackleton's
endurance
uh which to me is just incredibly
inspirational
um yeah i mean
it's i i have a hard time saying a
specific one
uh my my my assortment is everything
from ai superpowers like war
ascension machine burn in uh speed of
trust
great by choice all these things that
i've and here's what's bad i think
you've mentioned before others
i i write in the margins of every one of
these books
you know because they all they all
resonate with me and i hardly ever go
back or have the time to go back and
and look at those i'm now going back
through some of the books
to pull up some of my margin notes and
dumping them into whatever i
might produce someday to say oh god
there's just so much information out
there but i
i'm laughing at you describe me as one
of the better red i am
i always feel that i'm one of them less
you know i'm more more literate people
of the of the folks especially that i'm
dealing with now in the private sector
they're all
they're all you know very well read i i
think you're doing just fine
uh the next question is is brought to
our friends by
one that i would recommend especially at
the time and i don't think i got up here
is april 19 uh 1945 and it talks about
how lincoln holds the country together
right at that uh critical moment of
the civil war he's got a bunch of
generals that want to drive a stake into
the heart of confederacy
and he's think of this the guy's going
to get assassinated unfortunately a
couple months later
he's literally holding the generals in
to say whoa whoa don't want it to go to
a guerrilla war you know if we drive it
too hard you know you'll have some
places you'll be fighting forever we
want to bring them back together but you
think of that you think
lincoln's second inaugural when you walk
through the lincoln memorial
i mean you know what an incredible
leader um you know
just so it's too many too many books
whether it's history or other things out
there that uh
resonate with me i love that answer uh
sleep um if you are the uh the four-star
general in charge of special operations
command uh i'm assuming you're not
sleeping a ton
uh maybe now you're getting a little bit
more sleep but our friends over at eight
sleep they've got this thermo-regulation
bed that i've been sleeping on and i'm
now a
i say convert to the sleep religion
right of uh
i realize how important it is what's
your sleep schedule today and then how
has that changed over the years
it's much better now although i have two
colleagues that
are my alarm clock too early in the
morning every morning whenever they hear
the trash throat they're
that's when they start wolf and doing
timmy's in the well routine
um so it's much better now uh
unfortunately i grew up
i'm sure you had that experience in your
service time where the mantra was hey
you can sl you
sleep when you die you know you know
three hours four hours is good enough
and back to kind of the ai piece think
of the number of boneheaded decisions
you're making
when you're on the ragged edge um of
you know what you really need what
you're what your body needs and i've
seen people function on
little to no sleep but you got to wonder
the longer term effects so
it's better it could be could be much
better i'm a night owl
and i i have a tendency to stay up to
midnight or beyond
almost every night um only because
that's when i do some of my better
thinking or reflecting
um and i'm trying to curb that back in
to force myself to go to bed
and jump start the morning because i'm
not i'm not a morning person
i love it uh my last question for you
and you'll get to ask me a question to
finish up uh we talked a little bit
about space force and
and some of uh what i would consider the
the very practical kind of challenges
that we face
but uh on the topic of aliens uh are you
a believer in aliens or a non-believer
um i don't think and i'm fascinated by
these discussions which
literally has department of defense
attribution dripping
from them you know pilots and whatnot i
i'm a show me the money kind of guy for
anything that has happened here on
mother earth
um because i you know i think that one
we can't keep a secret
we can i mean i i lived the osama bin
laden piece where we actually did keep a
secret
up through execution uh and then it went
to a movie right away right so uh
i i don't believe that that uh we're
capable of keeping the secret
uh and so if if there was that there
there you know we'd all
we'd be a little bit more conversant on
it um do i think there's something
out there absolutely i mean i think you
know whether we're the
you know the fingernail and the big
scheme of things um
i i don't know but that's and that's why
i'm jazzed by the thought of space
exploration
um and just you know seeing what's out
there
um but i i don't know i don't know
what's out in the cosmos and i'm like
everybody else i'm interested in finding
out
i i feel the same way it's probably
somewhere out there i don't think
anything's happened on earth
uh i'm gonna cheat i'm gonna ask you one
more question because you brought it up
uh what were you doing
um in terms of military uh position for
uh the whole osama bin laden uh raid
i always mcraven's number two so if you
read his book he even tells you that the
humorous part was uh
and i gave president obama absolute
props for making a tough decision
when half the room was telling him just
bomb it just bomb it
and we'll see what happens and because
he listened to mcraven because he
listened to panetta
uh he decided that that's not sufficient
we're gonna do this thing we're gonna
confirm or deny that he's there
and we're gonna have that moment if if
he is there
we will at least you know realize that
we dealt with some unfinished business
although i'll point out there but hey
that was one man there was a network
there's still a network out there
and so to get caught up in one person is
is it's typically us we always have
public enemy number one
whether it's noriega or saddam or ubl or
whatever
um but i was i was his number two the
funny part he described in the book
was he kept that very secret um uh i was
his deputy i was number two
i found out a month and a half before uh
we executed
uh that he had been planning this for
several months with two other people
uh and with panetta you know so working
working with langley
um and that's when i got read on but he
didn't have the green light he didn't
have permission yet
so uh a week out he said hey
you me you go over do the final
rehearsal i've been part of the previous
rehearsals go to the final rehearsal
you may actually have to command it over
there because i
still have to brief the president unless
he says go and with enough time for me
to get over there
um you got it but it says a lot about
bill mcraven that he had no problem
saying
you know here one of the bigger things
we're gonna do lately i may have to hand
it to you
he got the green light in sufficient
time that he came smoking across
uh took over the main command control i
was his
backup um and then i joke with him that
he went back to all the victory parades
i stayed over there in afghanistan for
another month and a half
uh doing my doing my duty and then came
home
uh to my wife who was pissed off that i
hadn't told her about it and others but
i mean pissed off in a humorous way that
you kept a secret you know you didn't
tell me so when all this is going on
uh you know for those that watched uh
many of the movies read the books
uh basically there was an incredible
amount of obviously planning that went
on there was literally the recreation of
some of the physical structures
uh both i think in the united states and
uh and overseas
and kind of preparation what exactly is
going through your head
uh when they get on the two helicopters
and they're gonna go fly
into you know what could be you know a
pretty combative airspace and kind of go
execute what
you know at least in terms of headlines
is probably one of the most
notorious uh raids in you know recent
american history
is it excitement is it fear is it uh
we better not screw this up i mean just
kind of what's going through your head
um but i think mcraven describes it um
we did i think 12 or 13 other missions
that night
not in pakistan in afghanistan and
at least half of them were much more
harrowing or difficult
um we that's the kind of level of
operational tempo that
that we've lived for a long time of you
know
things that used to take months in
preparation for a one-night special
we were routinely doing that one you
know the hardest part and and mcraven
talks about the book
was the potential that the force might
get stuck in a badabad ironically if
helicopters you know had mishaps
um and luck as you might imagine we had
a plan for that and
and and it worked for us um but the
discussion on that was all over the map
in terms of
would we actually you know hunker down
would we surrender to
pakistani forces what would we do um
and and that would have been that would
have been a pretty anxious moment but um
but luckily again we planned through
some of those contingencies and we were
able to avoid it
yeah well you guys did a fantastic job
so uh we appreciate it
uh we've got five minutes and you uh you
alluded on twitter that you want to ask
me questions which scares the hell out
of me but uh what question do you have
for me
well you've uh again in my effort to be
tragically hip you've certainly made me
think a lot about bitcoin about
you know digital currency etc my my son
my oldest son is
uh uh has played a key role there as
well
um and as you might imagine a good
number of the discussions came back
to not to challenge you so much in that
and and i think the good news is you've
caused people
uh you know i'm i'm looking at michael
saylor and chalmeth every day
uh guys i have no idea who the hell they
were before just to
gain more and more insights into okay
what is this phenomenon uh there's still
a hell of a lot of speculation involved
but
but um you know so has every you know
huge new trend had you know those sort
of considerations but
so the practical question came back is
and i think you've answered that you
think
that we'll still stay based on a golden
and digital currency
kind of basis but with the emphasis you
put on bitcoin
how do we safeguard that other than its
inherent
you know trust system uh you know uh
if it if it migrates to where you want
it to be as part of our
uh both our institutional and our dod
and national security
approach to you know currency management
going forward
yeah i think one of the key pieces to it
is um yeah there's
obviously the technical uh kind of
system right and it's got more computing
power pointed towards it than any other
computer network it's you know in some
measurements the most secure computing
network in the world is decentralized
kind of all the things that
i think kind of labels just like the
headline comments about the
actual technical infrastructure one of
the key
pieces that i spend more time thinking
about today
and started to talk about more publicly
is just this idea that
when you have an open decentralized
protocol uh
you can't prevent somebody from using it
right what i mean by that is not so much
your own citizens right you can make
something illegal you can enforce on
you know certain people but on a global
scale that means that other countries
are going to use it
right and so what is the reaction to
that right and if you kind of look at
the internet as an open decentralized
protocol
uh one reaction is uh countries that you
you know mentioned as threats
china russia north korea iran etc if
they use the internet that could
potentially be a negative outcome for
the united states and so we can either
one say hey that's the united states
we're going to opt out we're not going
to use this open decentralized protocol
or two is we can say no actually we're
going to use it too but we're just going
to make sure that we use it better right
and kind of further our
position of leadership on on kind of
that global landscape
and so i think that bitcoin is actually
somewhat similar
in the sense of it's this open
decentralized protocol that other
countries are going to use right and so
the first reaction when people hear that
it's like well let's
not use it ourselves or it's used for
terroristic financing or
uh money laundering or whatever it is
but i actually think that the reaction
that we had to the internet
and we had a hand in creating it
obviously since that helped but same
thing here is we should embrace it and
we should say well
anyone's going to benefit from this
let's make sure we're the biggest
beneficiary right let's make sure that
we kind of
further our position and so when it
comes to kind of the geopolitical stuff
i think that's actually where there's
probably
less work that's been done so far and
kind of less
maybe consensus around kind of how the
uh situation plays out and what the
outcome is
uh from a technical standpoint i think
that uh there's always the concern
around quantum computing or some sort of
kind of leap forward in
a technical capacity but also you know
you as many others listen uh will know
is like
just as much as the nefarious or
malicious technology can improve
so there does the defense technology as
well right it's kind of this constant
cat and mouse game so
uh yes there are improvements in terms
of the offensive technology but there's
also simultaneous improvements
defensively and i think that
uh with bitcoin specifically there's the
the technical advantage it has in terms
of it's so far ahead by being the
strongest computing network
that it would take quite a bit of
technological
innovation to be able to attack it
without there being any sort of
improvement in the defensibility of the
network so i see that is kind of
unlikely
but even if it then happened uh then you
get into this world of like well if you
have the technical capabilities to
attack the bitcoin network
is that really the thing you would
attack right you almost get to the point
of like well if you
attack and violate the bitcoin network
then you kind of erase
all of the value right the whole value
is that it's decentralized it's the
strong computing network
uh and so would you be better off
attacking an electrical grid or uh you
know banking system or some other
kind of apparatus and so i i just think
that it's uh
you know somewhat of a foregone
conclusion that this open decentralized
protocol will persist globally
uh there's tons of questions around you
know who adopts it how
what's the impact of that kind of stuff
but i kind of throw my hands up at some
point just say look that's how a market
gets made right and people are literally
going to
essentially wager hundreds of billions
at some point in the future trillions of
dollars
on those outcomes and we'll kind of see
what happens
yeah i was going to ask you a follow-up
but i think you addressed it there
i was exposed to an interesting theory
recently that that we
the u.s the western world should be very
concerned with the amount of mining
uh and computational power that the
chinese are are
addressing this phenomenon with from a
from a state-sponsored standpoint
uh but i think your my takeaway from
what you just explained is if you're
not gonna compete you won't you know you
won't flat out um and and so
advantage them uh whereas if you
acknowledge it a lot a lot of effort
now and the the rest of that theory was
that they're mining and producing
to get us dollars in to pay for pay for
things which
again your fascinating theory anybody
want to challenge this anyone
you want to get uh
here's what i say is if every time uh
you know another country got an
advantage on
us if we just threw our hands up and
said oh they're gonna win you know uh
let's not play then uh we probably
wouldn't be the united states of america
right so i think that uh
we definitely like to stack the deck in
our favor uh we definitely like to
ensure that we're gonna win
uh but but sometimes it does take
competition and so i don't think that we
should uh we should shy away from it
so i probably should put a rapper
because somebody i i'm looking forward
to
you and i were talking earlier about all
the negative things that will come out
of that social media thing
i don't see china as this terrible
boogeyman
i do hope that people acknowledge
that this again is an ideological issue
um their thoughts on human rights and
human values
relative to ours and it really you know
boils down to
what kind of world you want to live in
and you can cherry-pick the uyghur
experience or whatever it might be
uh and and other chinese approaches to
uh dealing with human beings and you
could also just you know disparage as
they are right now
our western ways of dealing with the
human experience but
you know you're we're going to have this
you know this this clash of ideologies
in the form of economic military
diplomatic informational
uh you know nuances that that i don't
think we're ready for yet i think we're
getting there but
um it it it's it is a compelling
issue short of a threat if you want one
except as a threat that's gonna that's
gonna crop up here in the very near
future
i think that is uh very well said listen
general i really appreciate the uh the
time that you've taken today to kind of
go through this i think people are going
to learn a ton from it
where can we send people to find you on
the internet hopefully for all of their
positive feedback and
great questions uh but where where do
you want to send people to uh to find
you
god help me i'm on twitter um although
what's funny is i can't get one of those
blue check marks i've had people come
back to me and say why the hell are you
operating
without one of those you know twitter
put a uh an end on
the qualifications for that so uh if you
have
inroads with dorsey tell them that you
know
[Music]
uh but i'm i'm open and available on
twitter
um and then people have ways of finding
me otherwise i'm gonna give away my
email address or things like that i'm
i'm up on linkedin
uh for more uh i hope more i'll give
away the email
just stick to twitter and linkedin but
and i'm all about it so i'm it to your
point uh in the forever learning mode
um i am wide open to constructive
criticism so
um there were already some precursors
when you said you were interviewing me
today
uh you know that it show people's bias
and i get it um
but uh i'll probably i will turn them
off more than likely but if it's
constructive it'll make me think and
that that's
i'm all about that uh yeah i really
appreciate that view in the world so
thank you so much for doing this let's
do it again in the future
thank you continue success out there
keep making us think